in the opening scene we are shown the
desolate state of New England after a
catastrophic zombie outbreak has wiped
out almost all of humanity except for a
few survivors among these survivors are
two close companions Ben and Mickey
Mickey is a fastidious guy who values
cleanliness and strives for Perfection
but he lacks bravery and courage how is
Mickey still alive in contrast Ben is a
rugged Survivor who is unbothered by his
lack of hygiene and possesses bravery
and courage in abundance the two friends
embark on a journey through the winding
roads of Connecticut with no particular
destination in mind their primary
objective is to avoid detection by the
flesh-eating zombies that roam the
landscape and survived by Scavenging for
necessary supplies they also regularly
break into houses to look for food Tech
equipment or anything else that can help
them in the long run amidst the chaos
and turmoil that surrounds them two
close friends who share a mutual love
for baseball engage in the sport purely
for their personal enjoyment their
shared history how however reveals that
they were once trapped in a house in
Massachusetts with Mickey's Family for a
staggering three months tragically
Mickey's father mother and brother were
all killed before they were able to
devise a plan to escape in the aftermath
of this traumatic event Ben opposes
sleeping indoors which often results in
many heated arguments between the two
friends despite this Mickey wants to
live a normal life so he resists
learning basic survival skills he
constantly isolates himself by listening
to his CD player with headphones
draining the batteries during one of
their Scavenging missions the duo
stumbles upon a car with a female zombie
trapped inside Ben makes the daring
decision to open the car door allowing
the zombie to exit before promptly
shooting her in the head remarkably the
car remains in working condition which
fills the two friends with a sense of
optimism buoyed by this small victory
they set off once again on their
unpredictable Journey unsure of what
lies ahead as the day wears on the pair
finally arrive at the abandoned home of
Mickey's girlfriend which they proceed
to search thoroughly in a stroke of lock
they managed to uncover two functioning
walkie-talkies while experimenting with
the devices they unexpectedly stumble
upon a conversation between two
survivors named Annie and Frank overcome
with excitement they realized that there
is still life out there beyond their
isolated existence Annie and Frank
appear to belong to an organized group
of survivors called The Orchard and
Mickey who has not heard the sound of
another human voice for months
immediately reaches out to them with an
Earnest request to join however his
hopes are dashed when the group flatly
refuses his request they even warn him
to never contact them again before
hanging up the call frustrated and angry
Mickey lashes out at Ben expressing his
deep reluctance to embrace his so-called
hunter-gatherer way of life and his fear
of dying every day after this the two
continue their journey and come across a
nearby house as Mickey unlocks the door
a couple of zombies walk out but he
hesitates to confront them fed up Ben
steps forward with a baseball bat and
urges his friend to fight back against
the very creatures that killed his
family however Mickey remains adamant on
his decision he explains that these
zombies were also once humans so they
don't deserve to die for a second time
but in reality he's just scared to
confront the zombies hearing his lame
excuses Ben gives up and the two
continue on their Journey facing the
uncertain future ahead of them the next
day they wake up and set off in their
travels once again at one point Mickey
decides to sleep inside the car while
Ben decides to take a shower at a nearby
waterfall while Mickey is resting a
seductive zombie attempts to break
through the car window Mickey initially
panics and tries to contact his friend
for help but he eventually finds the
zombie attractive and starts to engage
in self-pleasure and people say zombie
movies never do anything new suddenly
Ben appears from behind and shoots the
zombie in the head splattering
everything on the car he then notices
Mickey's behavior and finds it amusing
causing the latter to feel embarrassed
as they continue their Journey they come
across a house in the forest and Mickey
suggests that they spend the night
inside because he wants to sleep in a
bed like a real human Ben agrees perhaps
to alleviate Mickey's frustration but he
takes away his CD player for the night
that evening Ben enjoys some drinks
music and dancing while Mickey tries to
connect with Annie on the walkie-talkie
to his surprise she responds but not in
the way he wanted and he sternly tells
him to stay off their Channel and stop
contacting her group as the orchard is
not the type of place he is seeking
early in the morning Ben becomes alert
to a strange sound coming from outside
the house as he goes to investigate he
comes across a zombie that has been tied
up near the house Ben comes up with an
idea and releases the zombie into the
room where Mickey is sleeping he then
shuts the door and urges his friend to
kill it with the baseball bat he left in
the room earlier despite Mickey's
initial fear and screams to open the
door Ben does not give in and instead
continues to encourage his friend
assuring him that he can do it a few
moments later the son of the struggle
stops and Ben opens the door to find
Mickey covered in blood it turns out he
has finally managed to kill a zombie Ben
is proud of his friends achie movement
but Mickey does not feel the same way
and he instead attacks Ben in Anger
before storming out of the house after a
while the two friends reconcile but
Mickey suddenly breaks down in tears
uninquiring about the reason he reveals
that Annie has forbidden him from
contacting her killing his first zombie
and getting turned down by a community
seems to have changed Mickey as the days
pass he begins to Take Ben's advice
seriously learning to fish and spending
less time with his headphones on this
change in Behavior brings the two
friends closer and they start enjoying
their time together more than ever
before one day during the course of
their Journey the two friends come
across a stranded car and decide to
investigate Ben attempts to siphon some
fuel from the car in order to replenish
their own Supply however they soon
realize that the car is already out of
fuel while they are contemplating their
next move a man named Jerry suddenly
appears and holds Mickey at knife Point
threatening to kill him unless Ben hands
over the keys to their car despite Ben's
attempts to reason with Jerry the man
refuses to back down and demands the
keys in a moment of quick think Ben
tells Jerry that the keys are in the car
and so the man releases Mickey however
when he proceeds to check he realizes
that he has been tricked in a fit of
rage Jerry tries to flee but bench
shoots him in the back and kills him as
the friends are recovering from the
traumatic incident a car pulls up and
two survivors approach them one of them
is a woman who asks them about Jerry's
whereabouts Ben honestly tells her what
happened and after hearing this she says
that he did the right thing because the
man was actually a thief who had stolen
their car following this her companion
refuels the abandoned car and prepares
to leave but just before that Mickey
recognizes Annie's voice from the
walkie-talkie and calls her name turns
out she is The woman Inside the car the
boys are ecstatic with the discovery
however the same cannot be said for
Annie fearing that the orchard group
will be found out and looted she shoots
Ben in the leg not only that she also
throws away their car keys into a nearby
field so that they cannot pursue her now
the boys cannot go anywhere as all their
supplies are inside the car in this
world simping gets you killed as night
falls Mickey and Ben continue to search
for the keys but can't locate them
anywhere Soon the Darkness deepens so
the two friends decide to sleep inside
the car hoping to resume the search in
the morning in the middle of the night
they are suddenly awakened by the putrid
smell of zombies that have surrounded
their car without the keys to start
their vehicle the two friends are
trapped inside and unable to flee the
situation worsens by mourning as more
and more zombies gather around them
preventing Mickey from venturing out to
search for the keys in the next scene we
see that Ben's injury is worsened so he
is now unable to even move properly
because of this they are forced to spend
an indefinite amount of time inside the
car as the days drag on the constant
presence of the zombies takes its toll
on both friends the endless noise smell
and sight of the undead weigh heavily on
their Spirits making it harder to cope
with their situation Mickey in
particular begins to feel increasingly
irritated and Restless he's not even in
the mood to fap driven to the Brink by
the constant presence of the zombies he
covers the car windows with blankets
hoping to block the outside world and
the sight of the zombies day after day
they pass the time by playing games
singing songs getting drunk and
sometimes simply sitting in Silence the
Relentless Siege of the zombies coupled
with the lack of food and water slowly
drains their spirits and leaves them
feeling hopeless despite their best
efforts it seems that they may never
Escape their Grim fate at one point Ben
encourages Mickey to go out and search
to the car key this time Mickey does not
hesitate and he finally decides to get
out via the sunroof as he searches Ben
Waits anxiously for his friend's return
hoping that he finds the key and returns
quickly after several hours Mickey
returns but with a deep bite mark on his
hands Ben panics knowing that the bite
could lead to Mickey turning into a
zombie and potentially infecting him as
well hence despite Mickey's pleas for
Mercy Ben is forced to shoot his only
friend and kill him the heart-wrenching
scream of Anguish that Ben lets out
after the fact is a testament to the
immense pain and the loss that he feels
with Mickey gone then is left all alone
in a desolate World overrun by zombies
the weight of the situation Bears down
on him as he grapples with the decision
he had to make it is clear that he had
no other choice but to take Mickey's
life as the potential consequences of
not doing so were too dire the feeling
of isolation and loneliness is
overwhelming and it seems that there is
no end in sight for Ben as he continues
to navigate a harsh and unforgiving
post-apocalyptic world after the tragic
death of his friend Mickey Ben is
consumed with anger and thirst for
Revenge he blames Annie For Mickey's
demise and vows to take her down to
express his hatred and rage then talks
to the walkie-talkie and threatens to
kill Annie however before he can act on
his threat he has to muster up the
courage to leave the car that has become
his only shelter in this
post-apocalyptic hellscape Ben's
Recollections of his past trapped for
months in a house only adds to his
anxiety and his apprehension however he
is determined to take action even if it
means risking his life according to Ben
he will just put a bullet in his head
said if his Escape Plan does not work
but if it does he will put one in
Annie's head with nothing to lose Ben
takes the plunge and escapes the car
although he's surrounded by a horde of
zombies that shamble behind him he
remains focused on his mission to avenge
Mickey's death he walks down the road
driven by his determination to find and
kill Annie despite the danger posed by
the zombies trailing him Ben is
Unstoppable with a Steely resolve to do
whatever it takes to complete his
mission
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching